a lot of people wonder why I'm living
here because I could live in LA or New
York and be building sculptures there
but the minute I drive up to my little
ranch here I feel like I'm onto
something that's never been done before
[Music]
my name is John Lopez and I'm a scrap
metal sculptor
[Music]
I use a scoop shovel I use snow chains I
use wrenches scissors gosh I use tractor
seats basically anything that is mild
steel it just so happens that I live in
a scrap-metal paradise because every
farmer and rancher in the area has a
scrap metal pile of some kind people are
very generous around here to invite me
over and say you can look through our
scrap pile and so that's where I gather
my materials for my sculptures so then I
bring all this found objects home that
I've hand-picked and I start grabbing
things and fitting them up there it's a
textural experience it's almost like a
patchwork quilt if you will it's got a
little bit of everything in it and
within all that chaos when you step back
the animal comes to life and scrap metal
should do that
[Music]
one of the most important things for me
is to be connected to the land South
Dakota inspires me I bought an empty lot
on Main Street and lemon and right next
to the park that I put it in was an old
bar called the Kokomo I cleaned the
Kokomo out renovated it and turned it
into a really nice art gallery where I
can feature and show my finished
sculptures I've had people come up to me
and express in emotion what it means to
them or I've had letters I've seen a lot
of scrap metal sculptures around but I I
don't think I've ever seen anybody
capture the life that my sculptures
capture and maybe it will affect some of
the kids that live here in their life
and send them off in a direction that it
wouldn't if I wasn't living here
[Music]
you